ينظر الي من طهران هادئه الدبلوماسيه
الايرانيه والسابق وبنكييف والاكزاندر
ميريكو رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في
البرلمان الاوكراني ابدا بضيفي من اكيف
لماذا كل هذا الانزعاج من المسيرات
الايرانيه
لانه في كل يوم الجيش الاوكراني يسقط على
الاقل 10 طائرات مسيره ايرانيه الصنع وهذا
يثبت ان ايران زودت روسيا باسلحه بطائرات
مسيره تستخدم ضد البنا التحتيه والاهداف
المدنيه
وفقا للقانون الدولي هذا يعني ان ايران
متواطئه بهذه الجرائم الروسيه ضد
الانسانيه وايران متواطئه في الاعتداء على
اوكرانيا مع روسيا في الحقيقه ان ايران
تشن حربا الى جانب روسيا ضد اوكرانيا
لمراه متعدده ايران نفذ انها كانت زودت
روسيا بالمسيرات ولكن مؤخرا اقرت بهذه
الحقيقه ولكن
حظ تستمر ايران بالكذب لانه وفقا لمصادرنا
وفقا لمعلوماتنا الاستخباريه رجال
الاستخبارات الايرانيون يدربون القوات
الروسيه حول كيفيه تشغيل هذه المسيارات
والربما حتى يقومونهم بتشغيلها وبالتالي
هذا يعني ان ايران مشاركه في الاعتداء
الروسي
من طهران يعني هنالك ايضا همم يعني
استغراب لصمت الايرانيين اولا مافيهم ثم
صمتهم ثم اعترفهم مؤخرا بانهم بالفعل
زودوا روسيا بطائرات مسيره كيف نفهم
الموقف الايراني
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم لك التحيه
والمشاهدين في الحقيقه
منذ ان ادعت اوكرانيا انه ايران تزوج روسي
بطائرات مسيره ابان الحرب نفت ايران وما
زال التنفي وحتى في التصريح الاخير السيد
امين عبد الله هيام اكد انه هذه الطائرات
المسيره اولا بعدد محدود وثانيا هذه بعتها
ايران ادت اشهر قبل اندلاء الازمه
الاوكرانيه هذا الموضوع الاول استاذ عامر
الموضوع الثاني والاهم يعني
الاكاذيب التي مازال يكررها كل يوم
طيب يا اخي نحن اقترحنا خلال مكالمه
هاتفيه واتفاق بيننا وزير خارج ايران
ووزير خارج الاوكراني انه نخصص وفدين في
دوله محايده اوروبيه وارسلت ايران هذا
الوفد كي يذهب الوفد الاوكراني ويتفاوضان
وتقدم اوكرانيا كل هذه الادعاءات الكاذبه
ويمنع الامريكي والالماني الاوكراني من
اليوسف الى لكي يلتقي لغرفه الايراني لحد
الان نحن نطالب اما وفد مستقل من الجهه
محايده من الامم المتحده او الاوكرانيين
فليبعثوا يرسلوا بوفدهم ويثبت ما الذي
يمكن انه ما الذي يمكن ان تصل اليه هذه
اللجنه اذا كانت هذه الطائرات تقول ايران
انها ارسلت قبل الحرب ويقول الاوكرانيون
انهم يسقطون به منها 10 طائرات يوميا واذا
كان الذي ارسل عدد قليل يفترض ان يكون
انتهى الان يعني هنالك ثقوب في همم
الروايه التي تقول عدد محدود اذا قرنها
بما يقوله الاوكرانيون فما الذي يمكن ان
تثبته اللجنه كيف يمكن التحقق
الحجه على الاوكراني انه نحن نقول نقدم
ولو يعني قطعات طائره واحده واكرانيه ولحد
الان لم يقدموا طائره واحده اسقطتها
اسقطتها الاوكرانيين تحمل يعني بصمات
ايرانيه لماذا هم عاجزون او لماذا يتهربون
من ارسال اذا تقصي حقائق محايده او التقاء
الوفدين
فالاعلام والحرب النفسيه الشيء والدعاء
على الارض واثباتات هذه بالوثائق شيء اخر
طيب ضيفنا من
كيفرجنكو لماذا فعلا حتى كان هنالك يفترض
يحدث اجتماعا سحب منه الاوكرانيون واذا
كان وزير الخارجيه يثمن هذه المبادره
لتحقق فلماذا لا يثبت الاوكرانيون
ادعاءاتهم بانهم يسقطون 10 طائرات يوميا
اثبات ذلك انا عضه في لجنه برلمانيه
يوم امس كان لدينا نقاش مع ممثل الجيش
الاوكراني وهو بنفسه يتحقق من الطائرات
المسيره التي اسقطتها الجيش الاوكراني وقد
شرح التفاصيل وكل الهيكليه والبنيه
والتكنولوجيا
المسيره هذه التي ايرانيه
واعطيه لروسيا لدينا الادله وكما قلنا
نسقط في كل يوم اكثر من 10 طائرات مسيره
ايرانيه لدينا البراهيم
عليكم ان تقدموها ايضا لكن اذا كنتم
تسقطون الطائرات الايرانيه بهذه السهوله
لماذا تعتبرون ذلك تصعيدارا لماذا تتحدثون
بقلق عن المسايرات الايرانيه
وانفرشه
نحن لا نتمكن من اسقاط كل الطائرات
المسيره التي
تستخدمها القوات الروسيه البعض من هذه
المسيارات
ضربت محطات طاقه كهربائيه
انقطاع في التيار الكهربائي لان روسيا
تستخدم
تحتيه المدنيه عمدا وهذه جريمه خطيره وود
ان اكرر ان ايران متواطئه في هذه الجريمه
مع روسيا
استاذ افقي يعني الايرانيون سكتوا كثيرا
قبل ان يعترفوا بوجود طائرات مسيره
ماذا لو ثبت بالفعل انهم ما زالوا يرسلون
طائرات مسيره لروسيا وان لهم خبراء كما
يقول الاوكرانيون
يعني هذه فرضيه نحن كانت حضرتك اسالت من
ضيفك يجب اثباتها وقال السيد عمر عبدالله
الان في نفس هذه التصريح انه لو ثبت ذلك
نحن سنعيد النظر وتكون لنا رده فعل عندما
تتحدث ايران
انه تعال
ربما تمنع يعني من الان فصاعدا اذا ثبت
ذلك مثلا قطع غيار او تمنع التعامل على
هذا المستوى فالان نحن الذي يحسم الموقف
سيدي هو اثبات هذا الموضوع الان هو ناقض
نفسه بنفسه انه لم يقدم هذه الدلائل لجهه
محايده يقول قائد الجيش الاوكراني اثبت
لانا نحن الاوكرانيين يعني هذه الروايه
الداخليه هم يتداولها بينهم في حلقه مفرغه
نحن نؤكد انه فليكن هناك وفدا اوكرانيا او
هيئه محايده تثبت لنا هذه الدعايه الكاذبه
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا هذه ابقى هي دبلوماسيه
الايراني
رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان
الاوكراني